i'm gonna start with this because it's a
frustrating thing for me um so i'm
curious uh how can a film win six
academy awards get nominated for ten but
the director not get nominated it's the
most asinine bizarre i mean that's why
snubs are such a thing and that's why we
all talk about them but that's a snub of
a snub of a snub
that i just thought was an impossibility
but given you know everything about the
academy awards there are many
impossibilities that actually
materialized so
it's all part of the game right now i
don't know is it post pandemic mentality
is it whatever whatever it is i don't
understand it he helmed the whole thing
it's his creation it's his
interpretation
and i love how he dealt with it then
i'll shut up but how he dealt with it
was all he did was go right into praise
for the 10 people who were nominated and
good for him i don't have to do that on
the other hand
dude neither do i i think first of all
dune is my favorite film of last year
by a mile denise a genius everything he
did with that movie is
amazing um
and you know so obviously if you've
never seen dune for the love of god push
play on it it's phenomenal you know it's
a it's a and we can't wait to get into
the next one which comes in july which
will be fun
which which leads me to my next thing
which is um for
i mean i know you're a part of dune too
but can you
confirm for people that you are a part
of doom 2 i am a part of doom 2 to the
to the ridiculous extent of when
somebody mentioned to me that wasn't on
imdb i actually went out of my way to
call liz and say can you please put that
on mdb because it's a proud moment for
me man i'm i'm and by the way javier and
i had a similar thing that we both
admitted to each other at the oscars
because we both have a little bit of a
punch right now
and and we had talked to didn't he we
hadn't read anything we talked to me the
week before and he was like you know you
guys are like fighting the whole time
and you've been in the desert with the
fremen and all that and we [ __ ]
panicked
like look down and saw this little
friend that we've been holding on our
abdomen and i was like i'm [ __ ] like
so we were both on like full diet mode
at the oscars even though you absolutely
couldn't tell we were on we were already
in diet mode in panic diet mode
that's funny but it will pay off when
you are filming in july it will
you